are you a new parent are you wondering
when life is gonna get back to normal
well we've got some great self-care tips
for you checks out of the hospital this
morning we just got back you you want to
come visit with with all the kids that
sounds great fantastic we'll see you
soon
mama you spent 48 hours in labor they
can wait 48 hours to meet that baby if
you want them to let's see how this
should have gone down oh you want to
come over we're actually not gonna take
visitors until next week okay man thanks
appreciate it all right we'll see you
soon need any help or anything no I
don't think so
yeah we're new parents should always
accept help when offered I recommend
keeping a list on your fridge of things
that friends and family can do when they
come over and give you that empty offer
to help let's see how that play out in
real life
actually yes we're out of milk and
diapers can you go to the store and get
some please the dishwasher is full if
you can empty it out oh the baby's new
clothes are just sprawled out all over
the living room and what else I don't
forget a pail
[Music]
there is nothing more important than
making friends with other parents no
matter how cool your regular friends are
they live on a different planet from you
now so let's see what Sean should have
done okay how's it going oh my god man
am I ever gonna sleep again depends how
old is she
he's two months old my first she started
sleeping about four to six months so you
got a little time before the sleep
starts hang in there you and your
partner made this baby together try to
remember each other's names so we see
that again I love you thank you Oh Jesse
[Music]
you're not truly a parent until some
well-intentioned stranger tells you to
sleep when the baby sleeps and while
that can be great advice it's just not
always doable here are some other
options you could do something you
missed like take a shower binge watch a
show spend some actual time with your
spouse
[Music]
[Applause]
right now it is hard enough those first
couple months if you guys are battling
each other every step of the way try to
remember that you made this thing
together and you're a team let's see how
dad could have done better
it's a demoness you go outside take too
much and I'll get her fit will you come
back come back
[Music]